I want to give a quick r.i.p to the 400
Starbucks that are closing as of today I
saw that and it looks like maybe the
market is turning around a little bit
yeah
as of today maybe yeah one thing that's
been wild past months gone up amidst
everything I mean yeah cuz you know
bailouts man what do you mean mm you
know government just just pumping money
left and right you know Boeing yeah good
dude
Boeing is always gonna be good that's
why I should invest in Boeing because
congressmen love Boeing I don't get that
yeah yeah it'll be fine
no matter what yeah look good to stop
flying yeah literally what's happened
yeah if anything it's way let's Boeing
is that like almost an all-time high
isn't it or am i probably dude
Boeing not all-time high but ambassador
past six months the [ __ ] got no
employees people quitting because the
airline industry is [ __ ] up but
somehow they're still profitable is [ __ ]
yeah we haven't flown a plane in 60 days
and our revenue is up 21% it's a it's
really been an amazing quarter it's it's
just a has to be fake everything's just
fake yeah yeah it's all it's all horse
so horse cottage it's complete horse
cred I haven't paid that much attention
to the stock market kind of pisses me
off it just goes up the only it just
goes up it's all spin it's all it's done
did you invest in anything maybe I
missed the investment now a lifetime I
know I know I but you know bought a
couple random stocks just because like
Tesla and [ __ ] like that you know stuff
like that it seemed like a safe bet and
just like you should have money in those
anyways yeah and then I sold everything
cuz it's just like I don't know
yeah just seems seems like it just
bizarre
it's something Tesla's that a thousand
dollars a share what the [ __ ] is this
dude one of two hundred dollars this is
the end of May
what the [ __ ]
I know it's funny it's like with stocks
are that expensive it's like even buying
one at stock even if it goes up 20% it's
like I didn't really you know I didn't
really make that much more than make
[ __ ] cuz I can only buy one bro
this is [ __ ] up man it was $32 back
whenever and I thought when it was 200
bucks that that was insane yeah it's
like Bitcoin man whatever yeah let's
look at Bitcoin
we got a cyst that's that's it that's
got to be a thing you know before we
were Bitcoin traders we got to be just
become day traders yeah that's it well
we'll just give everything up will you
give up entertainment to become day
traders you know market that only goes
out so good yeah
thank you guys so much for listening to
the podcast we want to announce a pivot
today that is when we talking about
futures today's picks corn yeah eight
yeah we should have a stock portion but
it's just all weird futures [ __ ] we're
investing in beans corn and celery stock
I love I love I like primitive futures
sound yeah this yeah gold beans corn
dirt hey he's gonna invest in grass
today's picks ocean water we think it's
on the rise as glaciers melt you know I
made a great move last week i I bought
six hundred bushels of hay and that [ __ ]
is a crazy man dude I just dude you can
buy gold and gold mini alright what else
is there mini mini gold mini gold it's
gold it's a smaller gold [ __ ] nine
years old man here's what I want bruh
soy beans oats dude vegans should be
doing this [ __ ] they're [ __ ]
this is all vegan right here you can
invest in rough rice okay
hard red winter wheat that's my favorite
type dude that sounds like a like wet
winter wheat dude that sounds like a
chewing tobacco hard red winter hard red
winter wheat you can't even say that
three times tack a lip of that stuff
nothing I love more than a pack of hard
red winter wheat when I'm out there
shucking my corn they do theirs there's
corn Minnie sugar [ __ ] off you can
orange juice no way what you can buy
orange juice futures
bro you can invest in milk this is wild
bro Jordan I'm shorting milk I'm
shorting milk this year he needs some
milk yeah
Oh God so CNN correspondent today up
next he needs some milk
literally your portfolio needs some milk
you